طائرات مسيره وعشرات الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه اجتاحت احياء مدينه رام الله
من كافه الاتجاهات
الهدف المعلن هدم منزل عائله الاسير اسلام
الفروخ المتهم اسرائيليا بتنفيذ عمليه
تفجيرا كانت ادت الى مقتل اسرائيليين في
شهر نوفمبر الماضي
بها جنود الاحتلال بمقاومه شعبيه في
الحارات والازقه حيث راشقهم شبان
فلسطينيون بالحجاره والزجاجات الحارقه
الجنود الاس
رائيليه
وقنابل الغاز فاصيب عشرات الفلسطينيين
واستهدف الصحفيون ومصورون
وبدلا من اغلاق المنزل بالسواتر او
الباطون قام جنود الاحتلال بتفخيخه
مشهد ظهر فيه جيش الاحتلال كانه يخوض حربا
وليس مجردا هدم منزل
العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه التي استمرت
لاكثر من عشر ساعات في المدينه التي
يعتبرها الفلسطينيون المدينه السياسيه
الاهم فانها حملت بنظر الكثيرين العديد من
الرسائل السياسيه قبل الرسائل الميدانيه
خاصه من انصار اليمين المتطرف في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
عائله الفروخ التي شردت وكل العائلات التي
تسكن في الجوار بقوه سلاح الاحتلال اكدت
ان هذه العقوبات لن ترهبها مهما عملوا
يعني من عنف ضد الشعب الفلسطيني او ضد
ضدنا احنا كاسره ما بناء من عزيمتنا ومن
كرامتنا بالعكس هاي اسمها تضحيه في سبيل
الوصول الى التحرير
الفلسطينيون راوا في العمليه الاسرائيليه
رساله سياسيه بان لا احد محصن مهما كانت
صفته ومكانه احنا رسالتنا رساله صمود
واحنا هذا المحتل الغاصب جربوا من 36 لهلا
وما في فائده واحنا هذه ارضنا واحنا
قاعدين هنا
معنوياتنا اكبر من امكانياتنا واحنا احنا
احنا موجودين واحنا قاعدين هذا المشهد
وحدث بعد سويعات من مباحثات كان اجراها
المبعوث الامريكي في رام الله مع مسؤولين
فلسطينيين مباحثات شدت على وجوب ضغط
الاداره الامريكيه على اسرائيل لوقف
العمليات العسكريه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
الجزيره رام الله